welcome to the recruitment roller
coaster podcast my name is heisha mazouz
today i'm very excited to be joined by
chris o'connell who has worked in
recruitment for
22 years started his journey at the
infamous
s3 then went on to start his own
recruitment business
which he actually exited in 2013
and then since then chris has been an nd
and leadership coach across
multiple recruitment businesses
and more recently has been very focused
on
purpose-led leadership coaching and most
of all
giving back to the industry that no
doubt has given a lot
to chris and his life chris thank you
for joining me
ladies i'm actually delighted to be on
your podcast i've watched many of them
and uh yeah you're
doing a great thing so thanks very much
man thank you appreciate that well
as i was just saying before we started
this we're definitely going to talk
about
chris o'connell the recruiting
entrepreneur ex-tinger business
why you rose to the top of s3 we'll
touch on those things but i think what
what i know you're keen on and what i'm
definitely keen on so
really focusing and honing on in on
today is
chris o'connell's mental journey right
what
sort of the mental um journey that
you've been on throughout this
career and the self-discovery that
you've been on
and i know that's something you're keen
to openly talk about
and uh really keen to dig into so where
i always like to start
is how you entered the world of
recruitment so
how did you end up at s3 let's start
there
well thanks i'll keep it brief i've done
this story quite a few times now i'm
trying to try to condense it down
um so it's in 1998 i kind of um
kind of fell into it like most people
did um and
yeah walked into the s3 office in
maintenance intense valley
uh as a very shy uh 21 year old or
something like that
it was um and anyone who knows s3 you
know even back then it was very very
kind of hardcore sales um what did you
do before
very dynamic i kind of um i went to
college university i had like lots of
different odd jobs i worked in a
sort of hardware shop where she worked
in a petrol station um i did i did work
for a call center actually
scheduling engineers around the country
which was interesting but this was my
first kind of major
proper job i actually went to university
whilst i was at estuary as well
part-time but um yeah i was overwhelmed
and really
really impressed with the kind of the
dynamic of the thames valley office
you know um everyone standing up
pinstripe suits shiny shoes
fast cars like a boiler room kind of
mad environment really but i took to
like a duck to water
and in the first year as a resource i
was top of the charts and
did very well um then
why um i think i think it was
i'll tell you the real reason why i
think i think when i was young my
my uh my mom abandoned me when i was two
and that gave me the
asked me a question i'll give you the
answer that that gave me the drive to
i really wanted to make something for
myself and do something tangible
and even though i was extremely shy and
that episode really really really did
affect me
um my mental health and everything else
which i'm happy to talk about
um i think i just wanted to present to
her and to myself that um i could do
something
um and not not for one moment i think it
will be recruitment
but i did always want to run my own
business um and i just i just walked in
i just felt this energy in this vibe and
i just thought it was hard to explain i
just thought
i can do this even though you know
everyone else was probably so much more
advanced more experienced than me
it just felt right so i can't really put
any more context
other than that really a big part was he
had a chip on his shoulder he had a
point to prove
pretty much yeah and that's why um
actually i
actually think that why was wrong then
at the time i thought it was right
um because i was doing it i wasn't
necessarily doing it for the right
reasons
um and to continue that then i went to
bristol
and became the uk top biller uh and then
the worldwide top builder
um was billing 600 700 a year year on
year
placing contractors into into various
different companies
and went way up senior consultant team
leader manager uh started to manage
offices across the uk
became the worldwide top biller and then
a five-year cycle probably made them
about 14 or 15 million quid
loved it if you cut me in half a bleed
s3 absolutely thought it was the best
thing since sliced bread
but then i woke up one day for what what
am i doing so i set up a business in
2003
um and then just quickly sorry for
context
yeah how long was your s3 for five years
five years okay so you choose that in
five years so
so just quickly a lot of recruiters
listen to this
yeah now we're going to talk about the
things that we're talking about but
just quickly like s3 fiercely
competitive
every person i've had on the show talk
spoken about
the culture where the standards are just
really high and everyone's sort of
rising to those standards and
looking to be the best version
themselves etc but like do
we spoken a bit about your why and that
you had you really had a point to prove
which is a big part the fuel behind
chris o'connell
like to smash net but anything else you
think you contribute to
i think people will be wondering like
why why was why was chris able to do
that
like why over all the people that you
competed against why were you able to
sort of build six seven hundred k
consistently
about how long he did i think it's
something that i um
i thought i've learned recently but
actually um i probably had ingrained in
me because of what happened to me
so i didn't put anybody uh i didn't deem
or approach anybody as superior
or didn't approach anybody inferior so
everything i did
i treated them as as as a level playing
field to myself so when i approached a
client
um or manager or director obviously if
they were my boss it was
slightly different but i just kind of
and that kind of really helped
me so for some reason i didn't really
have any fear
around around approaching any person and
also that was indicative of my approach
so business development
picking up the phone it wasn't the kind
of this this obvious kind of sales pitch
it was kind of more of a natural
conversation
um and it was quite funny actually um
you know the amount of clients i opened
up and my phone manner
uh is is i must sound different
understand a lot older than what i do
face to face
i go and see a client i'm going to say
no i want to see chris no it's me
i was about 12. on the phone i thought i
was about
38 because i just i just came across
with with this sort of level of
confidence um i guess it was easier over
the phone actually because
over the phone you know you they can't
see you and you you can actually
change your tone of voice and everything
else and what transpired was because i
was so shy and you know
i struggled with public speaking i
struggled with client meetings
i think i did well because um because of
what happened to me you know that that
kind of event that happens to you when
you're
you know a serious trauma can either
make you or break you
um but it kind of in my head it was like
what else can go wrong
nothing it's nothing not much worse than
can happen to that
so i thought sort this i'm going to
unders i was going to i'm going to
prove myself to someone and um yeah
that's what i did so
yeah that's really interesting because i
went i
it's interesting that because obviously
i'm sure now um
working with recruiters and like there
is that at the beginning
there is just that where i don't know
where it comes from but like you put
people on the pedestal right
and it's like oh i'm just calling this
client now
so that's really interesting that you
really contribute just the lack of fear
just because of what you went through
you put no one you thought none was
better than your normal was in fear of
you that that's really interesting
i think that's right and i think that's
that's what i kind of used as one of my
training methods when i
or when i when i coached and developed
people back in the day because i
actually
still believe now that a lot of
consultants they put clients on the
pedestal too much
and they can happily talk turkey with
candidates but actually they're the same
all human beings and that that's
indicative of where we are now i think
in in
in the current climate around what
leaders need to do around
um treating everybody the same um
perhaps we can talk about that later
in okay so then left
set your own recruitment business and
what year did you say sorry
2003 so i set that up with no money
really me and my business partner um
no money what do you spend all your
money on hey well you know
back in the day you earn and you spend
don't you
i won't tell you i won't tell you
everything but uh yeah just nice cars
and
and uh nice clothes okay so yeah so we
started
with the business part as you say yeah
um and
yeah in 10 years we won 14 industry
awards
so three best company awards in a row
which is very hard to get
three virgin fast track 100 awards um
and i think the reason why we did well
we had a good model
um but also um we were quite it wasn't a
one-size-fits-all training approach so
we were very keen
to understand each person's motivations
um
because you know some people responded
to different different things um
and uh yeah we had um 75
contract 25 perm in 10 years we got it
280 staff three offices
25 million pound turnover and uh we kind
of knocked the doors off it was a really
really exciting business
and we were really on the up i was kind
of southwest entrepreneur of the year
um and it was you know a very very
very very proud moment but i think um
during that time
um every single milestone that we hit
why hit you know
we hit it was um when i got there
it didn't actually feel as good as what
i thought it would um
and uh i'm not sure
i didn't know at the time why that was
and i think that was to do with my
purpose i think
i was i thought success back then on
fulfillment
and and and happiness was actually
hitting a number hitting a master and
getting a bigger house getting a bigger
car getting a bigger watch
and what's that that was that was nice
don't get me wrong i mean we went to the
monaco grand prix we know we did
loads of stuff as you as you as you
would expect you know and i was
quite exposed and quite let's just talk
about this for a second
because i think a lot of people can
relate to this and i think this is
like this is sort of the learnings that
people go through right and i think it's
interesting
i know it's just a bit of a flip and
comment on what did you spend all your
money on but
i think this is linked right how many
people sit down with chris o'connell 24
year old going hey chris
this is what i did when i got all this
money this is what i learned
maybe this i'm not going to tell you
what to do with your money but this this
is uh what i learned what i went through
um
spending getting that it's great but it
doesn't last
right so yeah just talk a bit about
how how you felt because i think like
i think that's just really common right
you hit these milestones you get these
awards you're
you're on the face of it you're going
somewhat wow this is doing well and i'm
sure you always got that right chris wow
like you know deep down you wasn't as
happy as you thought you'd be right so
what did that actually feel like well i
think firstly in order to get
to that level of success i mean there
are people out there done
much better than that but it's a pretty
good pretty good story pretty good
success story i think um you have to put
i had to put my literally my heart
and soul into that so i kind of lost
relationships i lost
um family i lost health um
but i still had this insane desire to
let literally no matter what i achieved
i want more
and more it kind of felt it kind of felt
there was there was no it was a
limitless boundless kind of
no fear and i almost became the victim
of my own success my [ __ ] that's
i talked about what happened i think i
almost became
i felt i was untouchable in a way and
whilst
whilst having that drive that that that
passion to push forward is is
intrinsically important to get to that
level
you can do sort of reality so i it felt
it felt good but it almost it didn't i i
look back
actually and i i question whether how
how
how much genuine connection i had with
my with my people
um in terms of that bond and that
relationship um if it felt good
uh it felt brilliant it felt you know i
could buy
anything i wanted um but i i didn't
really have
a decent personal life because of it and
it kind of sacrificed a lot of a lot of
that
and when the business isn't there what
you left with you know and that's one of
the things that
i've learned um and so when that's
really interesting
when so when you say you've lost
relationships what we're talking here
did you have a wife did you have
i don't know what what what sort of came
as a sacrifice
i mean because i think that's also part
of it right where a lot of people
again like don't don't talk much about
that or don't put hand in hand with
right if you're gonna put those blood
sweat and tears and sacrifice
that potential yeah your relationships
are to suffer so what what did you lose
and what was that
like well if i knew then what i knew now
i would do it differently i would i
would
um delegate more and i would spend more
time with my family and still have that
balance but
i lost um quite a number of
girlfriends um i lost contact with my
son
um who i haven't spoken to for three
years um
and i became very stressed
uh and to a point was having panic
attacks so i couldn't actually stand up
in front of my own company
and do presentations because i was even
though it was a
brilliant business um i uh i just kind
of
i i'd quite often go into into my car of
an afternoon sleep for 20 minutes
because i was so tired and drained by it
all
so all that glistens isn't gold so
that's
that's the misconception people have
with leaders you know
um you know although i was
self-completely self-made millionaire
now i'm small in a caravan
and then on the council state you know
nothing was given to me completely
self-made
um and people don't realize what it
takes to get there but when you get
there isn't actually as good as what you
think it is
unless you find that balance so um i
think i lost my uh
my way really because um
i became quite arrogant quite
egotistical i'm not saying everyone does
this
um you can't because i put my suit on
and became this kind of person that
wasn't me so you have to be this kind of
resilient stoic
inspirational motivational ruthless kind
of person
and oh my god i mean some of the stuff i
did in work was was was
was phenomenally ruthless i should say
i come home and kind of like could be
completely different
so um
now i'm encouraging leaders to be
themselves and and still have to have
still
get that good performance and i think
back in the day that my that old
approach did kind of work now
it's all about compassion empathy
understanding being a human being on a
level playing field
so i've completely changed my mindset on
that but yeah
so just on this
did people know like did people know
that
chris was feeling like this no not at
all why
because i would at that time at that
moment in my career there was no there
was no way on earth i'd
i'd allow anyone to think there was any
weakness god
heaven forbid um i've changed that now
but it was it was just
kind of like i wouldn't say it was
management by fear
i think it was because it wasn't it was
it was more kind of like
you know i wouldn't take any prisoners
and but if they if they didn't know the
real me actually probably would have got
even better results out of them but no i
i was very um
focused on just driving driving
performance and
don't get me wrong i mean i was quite
good one on one and i was very good at
sort of reviews and bringing out the
best of people understanding the soft
side of their skills but i wouldn't i
wouldn't necessarily
ever let my guard down so
i think if people knew really some of
the
mental health issues i've had and um the
problems i've had they might
see me differently so on that point
actually i think
um people misunderstood me rightly so
because of the way i acted but
in that position and when you've got
mental health or when you're a leader
when you have to when you have to kind
of perform under under dress
um for me um i found it difficult to
engage with people
sometimes i was quite shy in social
situations which is quite paradox being
a successful business leader
and that kind of led to people thinking
is he arrogant does he not like me am i
not worthy to speak to him it's kind of
like all these different things and i
think back now why don't i just be my
bloody self
why didn't i just you know open up and
be vulnerable um because then that would
create that back
from the other person then we can have a
real conversation and
and also then what impact this what did
you have no
was there no one that you could be chris
around besides yourself
because as you said you had the
sacrifice that's also the hard part
right
there's no one else then that you could
get more comfortable or used to
letting you go down that's interesting
totally
what what i was going to say um
so i'm just trying to sort of so when
did this start to change then so
obviously you then exited your business
in 2013
yeah what did that feel like well i mean
a private equity partner came in
and there was a two-year kind of phase
i became a ceo and then i eventually
exited so that was a difficult
challenging period because it was a
different animal really um
it was more geared around arriving at a
number and we kind of
the soul and the culture of the business
wasn't as important it was to me but it
wasn't necessarily to them
um so i eventually exited that 2014 and
i took
four years out three and a half four
years out honestly it was
it was a huge contrast from i say this
all the time but you know from being a
very successful ceo of my own
world of recruitment so then kind of you
know watching supermarkets sweep or
judge judy every day it's a big place
you know it's a big it's a big big thing
man
and that really really kind of my mental
health dipped
you know what did you have a plan what
was like so what was the init because i
think a lot of people think about this
right
i think i mean you don't hear it before
and more in your time you'd hear yeah
i'm gonna stop my own recruiting
business i'm going to sell it
like i don't think that's as common now
it's definitely achievable from the
conversation i had with people but
like what like just talk to us about
what sort of chris's vision was
for this deal like was it the right i'm
gonna sell this business and i'm going
to
sit on the beach like i'm going to like
i'm going to be happy where
do you know i mean what was the what was
you hoping it would be and then we can
talk about the actual reality
sure so i mean i think it was around
2010
um my kind of business partner decided
that you know he he wanted to exit the
business which is fine i think he just
had his third child
we just opened up manchester so we had
three offices and it was kind of like at
his point in his life he wanted to to
exit that which was
which was great but was a bit of a
surprise to me so then we had to find a
vehicle or parliament to buy him out
which we eventually did
i chose a particular private equity
vehicle that i felt would
um accelerate the business even faster
over a three to five year cycle and get
it to a certain number that would
enable me to literally not have to work
again so the plan was when i
engaged with that privacy partner was to
was to do that
um it didn't work again oh can i never
say that
but you know but a lot of people think
say that though a lot of people think
that
right i want to do this so then i don't
have to think about like or have to like
you're not alone in that so many people
will have that visualization or
thought so yeah but i or at least
certainly put me in position where
i did if i wanted to i didn't have to
you'd be financially free you wouldn't
have to
you would no longer you'd not stress at
all about money you'd be able to provide
for the people who want to
all those things absolutely so
but it didn't quite work out like that
for various reasons so
i i actually did the business two years
two years later and
um kind of the financial aspect wasn't
uh where it should have been so it kind
of
there wasn't really a plan based on that
because a
um i was completely drained and affected
by
uh losing my effectively being out of
the industry and losing my business and
losing because
before this happens you know my vision
as planned was to
literally go global and you know god
knows where that business would be now
that didn't happen
so that was kind of taken away from me
which was which was a huge
a huge a huge hit to me mentally um
and i kind of i kind of lost my way
really
um and i can talk to you about that that
journey and then
i've moved away from that now and then
completely changed my mindset around
what's important to me
so for context you exited the business
but you didn't quite hit the numbers
required for you to get what as much as
the payout that the
initially hoped for but you x to them
and then yeah yeah talk to us then
well i i think that um uh
yeah i mean the business was built on um
our culture and our soul
and our camaraderie and
you know the two founders built that up
and when one of the founders goes and
a completely new partner comes in with a
completely different agenda
um there were some fractions and
therefore
kind of the business kind of disbanded a
little bit
um so the whole objective where the
business was going
had completely changed um and it would
just reach the point where it was best
that
um you know it was it was we went in a
different direction
so um i had to take some time out anyway
because
uh i was i was completely burnt out and
uh
and that's what i did so i was left
with uh wondering what i was gonna do
next really
um and it took me three years to kind of
get out of that malaise
of of kind of my hopes and dreams of
what i thought would be success kind of
to take taken away from me um but i'm
much more happier now
i'm now as a millionaire at 25 26 you
know you know
buying 40 grand watches for fun kind of
situate whatever you know
so now you know i've got nowhere near as
much money now um but i'm i'm rich
in in purpose fulfillment my my my
purpose now is to give something back to
the industry
to to help them with or
or at least at least at least share my
story around
um some of my mistakes and some of my
pitfalls and
also some of the you know
what what what is success success
necessary
isn't necessarily a number or an object
to me success is actually
um being happy in yourself but also
providing a service to others
and that's that's what i'm trying to do
at the moment yeah
yeah i'm really excited to get into that
i think what i just want to
what i'd love you to just talk a bit
about because i think a lot of people
might be able to relate to this chris
and a few things totally different
circumstances but
how many people's purpose has been taken
away over the last three or so
months right how many people before they
went on furlough
made the time to work out who they are
what their drivers are why they do what
they do
like how many people just got just got
up and did what they did right
how many people made the time to sort of
self-discover and and those things right
so then
for no fault of your own because of
what's going on i'm then taking away
your
job and taking away your routine that
are there so i think
i think there'll be a lot of people that
can relate chris on like that journey
that you went on right because
like you didn't you wasn't straight away
found out that that's what i wanted to
do this is my purpose so
it'd be great to just if you could just
talk a bit about the sort of hardship
that you had to go through or
some of the dark times that you had to
experience or from those dark times you
start to see the light and work these
things out but what
where where was you before like what was
going on and what did chris's life look
like
for before you got before you got to the
point where you are now
well i think um i had it got to the
point where i had some
some addiction issues as well because i
didn't know what to do with my life so i
had more time than i ever ever had
before and when you're used to kind of
just
just everything being successful and
having the right money and hitting all
the targets
you're left with nothing it kind of like
does play with your mind so i was i was
depressed
i had some addiction issues i wasn't
motivated um
very lethargic lots of things mate
you know no no gambling
um uh kind of love addiction around just
you know
different aspects of um um
maybe cut that bit out um
you know shopping buying stuff just
cause obviously
doing what i'm doing um you know hitting
every target
that becoming became addictive so i i
believe i could do and
hit anything and to get that kind of
dopamine hit around yeah
you know it was it was it was going out
and buying buying stuff i didn't really
need
or going to really expensive restaurants
just for the sake of it or
holidays or just to get that kind of
that fulfillment but what i wasn't doing
was was engaging with my friends or
doing any personal development
and it kind of spiraled down and i just
i just kind of let myself go really
um and um
[Music]
it was only only only up until last year
actually about 12 months ago
um i was divorced you know year and a
half ago left the family home
and that was really the catalyst not
that you know i'm not
i'm not i'm saying that this year was
the best year because because
everything else was but worse this year
has been good to me because
i told my own to reflect to look at
myself and go actually
well actually well done mate you know
don't be
don't keep beating myself up too much
that um
you know i'd never give myself any
praise what i achieved has been
it has been amazing so instead of
looking at all the negatives because a
lot of the reasons why the business
went well was down to me and a lot of
the reasons why the business didn't go
well was down to me as well and i'll
happily admit that
but i think i think the turning point
was having that time on my own taking
that time out and thinking hang on a
second
i i'm alright i can do something here
but what why
why what can i do and here i hear after
four years out in the wilderness
here i am talking about mental health
about purpose about vulnerability about
courage
completely different animal to what i
was like before and i think what i'm
trying to say is probably not very well
is um losing my losing my mom
being abused as a child which i haven't
talked about becoming an addict
losing my business losing my son like
five
there's loads of other stuff there's
five things there that would would
destroy most people
um but actually i see those as a gift
in a way because it is really helped me
understand me as a person
but also i'm using those experiences to
a positive way and actually
um i now know i'm a very resilient
person
and sometimes adversity can actually
help you
uh help you to help others so i don't i
don't ever want to experience
those again but i i kind of now i see it
as a strength really
almost please it's happened to me what
do you think made you
change the way you look at those things
because look this this came up with
a chat that we sort of really sort of
dug into
his darkest days in the journey that
he's been into a guy called um
chevy ruff and um like he didn't so what
what he recognized which he sort of
openly spoke about was
again he sort of got to a place where he
was aiming for got there
felt empty it was when he took his first
anti-depressant pill
and so the journey he went on was
recognizing that he didn't actually
he was always on the move always wanted
to do something which meant that he
didn't have the time or freedom to think
about his demons which was his childhood
and these types of things so
i guess what i'm trying to say is like
clearly you didn't always look at those
things that you just described in
in the way that you do now right so i
guess what do you think
helped you have that perspective or
change your
percep perception of well actually these
are a gift they're not
things that do you know i mean because i
think that's the part that people find
most difficult right
is that my past defines me and these
things these things happen to me because
i wasn't good enough or
what whatever right and clearly you've
been on that own journey of recognizing
that
well actually no the this is how they've
helped me and this is it
made me eye in a positive way i don't
know anything around that
yeah i think so i think um i think it's
the loss
you know the the quantum and and the the
amount and that
of the loss and so i'm not saying that
you have to go out and
lose your family in your business to get
purpose but i think i think i think
sometimes when you are at rock bottom
um you know it's the only way to snap
you out a bit and actually
i think if those things didn't happen to
me i might be dead somewhere or whatever
you know
that sounds a bit dramatic but um
yeah i think i think uh but also having
that time i think i think
you know where leaders fall down is that
they don't give themselves that personal
time they don't speak to enough people
around them don't have mentors
you know i've i've hired four coaches
this
last three or four weeks on various
aspects of where i see i can improve
and that's the other thing i think
leaders well i certainly got into a
position where
you know i thought i didn't need any
coaching or development and i think who
coaches the coach who leads the leader
you know you've got to have people
around you you've got to talk to people
um but it's a very lonely place as a
leader
um sometimes and if you've got no one to
talk to or if you feel you've got no one
to talk to
how the hell are you going to change
that and actually what you need is
you don't need friends to go well done
mate because i had lots of people around
me going oh look at you you're brilliant
all that kind of stuff but i didn't have
anyone saying mate
actually you'll be with dick yeah at the
um time uh you know that's that's what
you need
and i think that no matter how
successful you are there's always
someone who's earned more money or done
something big and just done something
better
um and i just wish back then i had that
more human
element to me which of which i've got
now um but you can't change the cost
so what as you as you started to when
you
ended up spending time on your own time
to process
yeah and sort of get to the place you
are now what i guess what really helped
you during that period then what what
became sort of non-negotiable for you
did you start to form some good habits
did you
start building new relationships with
people that really helped like i don't
know what what do you think
was was really impactful in sort of
really helping um
shape where you are today as you sort of
climbed out of that darkness
it's not easy when you've got kids wives
dogs you know all sorts of things but i
think i think um
what the catalyst was to actually say
look
i need to put myself first not in a
selfish way but in a selfless way right
whereby
i need to have this time to to look at
myself
do therapy whatever it is you know
understand you know spend some time
and work out what i want to do and i
love myself
actually and once once i achieved that
honestly this last 12 months
some of the stuff that's happened to me
has been absolutely phenomenal so just
just things like looking in the mirror
pretty much every morning and looking at
myself and saying
actually mate you're all right that kind
of stuff talking talking to myself it's
a bit weird but actually it works
um and just and just kind of saying
actually what you know
looking at the facets so instead of
spending 98.99
of my time focused on work balancing
that out work
personal life exercise diet nutrition
looking at seven or eight different kind
of elements in my life i'm raising them
out of ten
like works ten personal relationships
one um exercise two what ah
this might be why i'm not i'm not
finding that balance
and then actually switching the dial and
then saying look right
this next two hours i'm gonna listen to
a podcast and put it in the diary i'm
gonna commit to do an exercise and all
this kind of stuff and then actually
writing down the list of my friend
i haven't spoken to them you know no one
instead of me getting pissed off with
them
for not when was the last time i did
something to them was last time
i reached out to them and looking at
every almost everything else apart from
work
because i i believe that a lot of
performance related issues in work is
only
is related to stuff outside of work so
you can have the best brand the best
training the best kpis all that
[ __ ] um but if the mindset purpose isn't
right outside the world that person
isn't going to perform
so it's all that kind of stuff basically
looking at everything else
and that sounds quite selfish but it's
not once i'd done all that
honestly i found i had more time i was
more engaging i was more affectionate
i was more compassionate and actually 10
times more productive
yeah you worked on yourself whereas yeah
you didn't
have time for that before you just knew
what you had to do to keep leveling up
your game to hit the numbers or whatever
that i meant that makes complete sense a
quote that
sort of was always stuck with me which i
think is so powerful
on the part around loving yourself i
think that's so important to highlight
that
is no one the quote is no one can love
you more than you love yourself
and that really stuck with me right
because
um i've experienced that in
relationships
and like i've just always thought that
like for me
thinking of relationships and how that
relates is like for me there's nothing
more attractive
in in a female if you know deep down how
much they love themselves
absolutely rather than seeing the sort
of what they're trying to be or what
they
they only see their downfalls or
whatever so
that i completely get that that makes
complete sense you actually made the
time during that period to recognize
what right no
chris i am good enough and and that's
that's so common that people don't make
the time to do that
i think so man i think on that point
about the the relationship so you know
i attracted the wrong sort of woman in
in my life because i was probably too
uh you can see me a mile off although i
was very successful
um i probably had kind of you know [ __ ]
written on my forehead in terms of like
do i mean so i i was so obviously
vulnerable and so obviously kind of
putting on this mask and this act
to an extent where you know
the people that i attracted yeah
attracted were were the wrong type and
now it's now it's different ball game so
on that point you're right it's not just
you know you're not you're not even
capable of attracting the right people
or things in your life if you're not in
the right mindset
yeah totally yeah so let's talk a bit
about the things that you've been
in the sort of last 12 months what
you've been seeing
talking about why you think now much why
actually
leadership yeah your power is being
vulnerable your power is being
human so i guess what are the sort of
the
on that front sort of the lens that you
have what are the common
things you see in leaders that you think
will actually
yeah i don't know what are the things
that you think that leadership
is missing out on or i don't know what
what have been the common things that
you've been saying
yeah i think i think going are the days
where
leaders or companies uh are going to be
motivating people or pushing people on a
number a target and a profit number
obviously that's important
but i think i think so i've walked into
as an nd i've walked into many
businesses and they've got their five
purposes or their five
you can't even spell the word integrity
a lot of it is is is taken from others
it's not actually real um so i i think
that there's a huge
shift around because of what's happened
with lockdown and covid
half the workforce aren't ready to
literally come back to work mentally
and i'm hopeful that a lot of leaders
will understand that and have more
compassion and empathy towards that
because they've been in that situation
themselves
but what i do think will happen is i
think i think there'll be less of a
hierarchical kind of structure to a
company whereas
leader at the top dictating um i think
there needs to be
and there will be more of a shift
towards a community-led
um way of running a business don't get
me wrong needs to be leaders but i think
i think
in order for the companies to get the
best out of their people
they're going they are going to have to
be a bit more human they are going to
have to understand their compassions
their mindset
their their mental health their their
purpose and their why
to get the best out of them because even
even on a macro level when you
when you train someone right if you just
bring people into a room and do a role
play
you know half the room all hates it
halfway or presentation
is it's about understanding what what
what what receptors each each person has
and that isn't just
you know a one an archetypal
one-size-fits-all this is our company
this is what we're going to do
people respond to things in different
ways so i think leaders
will get the best engagement out of
being a bit vulnerable being a bit open
with their feelings not too much but
just having that human side so
you know i had an example i spoke to a
colleague last week actually
and i i i was bugging me i quizzed her
uh i brought her in actually in the pub
and said uh what was all that about
three months ago in terms of um
you know your your performance your lack
of motivation
and i did it in a way look i'm doing
this from the point of view where
i'm trying to help you my job is to
guide you and and drive you forward
where like where have i gone wrong as a
leader kind of thing and i was by the
way she said look you know
i thrive and i flourish and i'm uh i'm
really impressed
i love your leadership it's absolutely
brilliant the reason why i was going
well is because i felt i was
on a level playing field with you in
terms of communication i could talk to
you as accessible
i wasn't in fear of you but towards the
end of that kind of
project um it became like
i was scared to pick up a phone to you
and you you it was it was a little bit
like management like fear so but
effectively she was scared of me
well i was like i was like wow yeah so
instead of me thinking it was her it's
actually it was actually my style
that was causing her you know and i you
know nine times out of ten you take it
with a pinch or something yeah whatever
but actually i think back to you was
right
so it's that kind of thing where you've
been in tune and been being able to
put put yourself on that as i said
earlier put yourself on that same
position
to then get the real the real the real
deal and that's that's that's the art
master the thing i'm looking to to kind
of push forward with
what why do you think why do you think
why do you think that can help you
become a better leader
as i just said because because people
people
it's more of a all-round approach to
actually get understanding your people
intrinsically
because you can push and push and push
and say make more calls or do more stuff
and do more stuff but
people don't want that anymore people
want to have a
have a connection and an understanding
and
uh it's about giving something back it's
a different form of motivation as well
and i think that um there are a lot of
leaders that are going to be in trouble
uh in terms of how to prom
it's a lot it's a lot about self
branding as well so
as you know linkedin and you know a lot
of companies are forced to tell them
tell their sell their brand viral story
and a lot of leaders don't have
necessarily the capability to do that
because all they know is about
look at our company look and it's
actually no it's about engagement people
are buying from people
you know i've got some one or two man
band businesses that
deal with huge accounts because it's a
one-on-one
engagement so they need to adopt that
with their
with their employees but also there's
some of their sales approach so make
them a better leader because they'll get
more business
and they get more engagement um yeah
so i guess what's coming up for me is
sort of
if i'm a leader listen to this right now
and i'm going you know what chris you're
completely right
no i i i do under i consciously i do
understand that that's going to help me
get more out of my people yeah but how
do i start like
that like do not mean you as that person
right you never was that person to
sort of have those vulnerable
conversations go actually
where can i improve what did i do wrong
previously right so
this is the thing right how can you
start that shift
in because a lot of people may listen
and know that that's
like that's important right but yeah
they have no idea where
to start because they've always done
what they've done and that are there so
i guess i don't know what have you seen
what have you sort of helped the people
you've worked with or what you've seen
what's helped people start to make that
shift
i think i think um what i would do and
what i have done
is um bring everyone in one-on-one
and have that one-to-one even if it's 20
minutes half an hour the power of that
as a starting point now rather than
delegating it out
you know bring bring your most junior
person in bring your
everyone in one to one and have uh have
that have that conversation with them
and pretty much like i just explained
say look you know i'm bringing you in
because
you know kobe has been difficult for me
my friend well you know something like
that where it's not kind of like
it's more of a human conversation maybe
not even talk about business just just
kind of have that conversation and build
it out from there
and i think but i think there's got to
be an element where you've got to be
willing
to say how can i improve as a leader
yeah absolutely i'm not everyone's
willing to do that
well they're not but in order but that's
like one of those
as i said earlier you know who who
coaches the coach who leads the leader
you know i mean even the great coaches
tony robbins or whatever he's got
he's got his own coach you know and it's
about it's easy for someone like me to
say
i i continually focus on improvement and
telling it to others but where i've
where i've evolved is and this is where
i am where i am now i'm aware that
i need to be doing that for myself and i
wouldn't ask someone to do not
something i'm not prepared to do myself
so i think it is
that first step is always the hardest
you know people say they want to change
they want to have purpose
they have got integrity unless unless
you actually make action you haven't
so it is saying look if i want to
achieve that i am going to have to
take off my leadership cap take off my
my coat of armor
and bring in karen from from accounts
and say
actually what can i do to help i feel
that i feel that
whatever yeah no i i just think i love
that and i just think that's
obviously part of that challenge as well
is like if i'm a leader in a business
and there's no
i don't know there's no other leaders
for me to look up to or learn from or
yeah i can see they're doing they're
approaching like that that could
that that could you're completely right
and i think that's also part of the
challenge isn't it where
if there's four leaders and you've got
three the old chris
and you've got the fourth which is like
right i'm really prepared to become a
better leader
over the last three months i've
recognized that i haven't been great at
communicating to my team when they've
been demotivated i've found it hard
clearly
i don't know i need to upskill myself
here the coach the coach i think that's
part of it isn't it because like who
who's helping these people become better
leaders not everyone has that support or
i don't know i think i think that's part
of it isn't it i think that's right i
think absolutely and the only way to do
that is actually so
again over the last so when i was
running my business i don't think i was
really in contact with many of my peers
and my colleagues around it was all kind
of this competition thing wasn't it
you wouldn't let your guard down now i
think that's completely changing
where like you know there's a community
of like you guys there's lots you know
you've got other people in your sphere
and you'll share ideas and that's what
i'm trying to get to
so i think um
uh yeah
yeah no no i think i think i think that
if you're listening right now and go you
know what i'm that person
ask for help that there's plenty of
people that will
probably going through what you're going
through that would be willing to help
right i think that's the thing that
you'd be surprised how many people are
willing to help even if that's to reach
out to you or
you've seen someone on linkedin that
sort of looks like he's leading his
team in the right way drop them a
message and say hey hey chris look
love the way that from what i can see
the love away you lead your team your
business through this period
i want to become a better leader how can
we go about helping each other
where is so i guess reach out yeah reach
out for help
i think so i think i think you know what
i've learned on linkedin actually is
that instead of always promoting or
sending out a video or of my own stuff
absolutely comment other people's stuff
so what i'm really impressed with that's
the range of zoom
whatever and that that's that's where i
think things are changing
certainly with the people who are who
are changing or want to get something
out of this
if you continue with this insula no this
is our company we can't bring any other
kind of
you know you are you are actually going
to get swallowed up and i think i think
it has changed and i think
i think as well um you know put a funny
video out of yourself
do you know do something a little bit
different um
give something back to the sector and
actually um
you know i've going back to the superior
inferior thing you know i've i've
recently had a conversation with the
most qualified brain
science neuroscientists because about
this mental health thing i'm doing
and held court with them because i
didn't manage to do that but also
having conversations with what you you
deem as much more junior people and
learning that as well so it doesn't
necessarily have to be people at your
level as well you know that's true
put yourself out there and just it's
about if you see something good
that benefits you don't have the mindset
or better not comment on that because
they'll get they'll they'll get their
credibility
no i'll go the other way and if i don't
matter who it is if it's good i will say
well done mate
bloody brilliant yeah can i learn
something from you
absolutely spoken a lot about your
journey leadership
let's talk about yeah so obviously um
someone that we both know someone has
been on this show and people know ronda
d'ambrosio
yeah sort of great mission mental health
and recruitment
not-for-profit organization if you don't
know sort of who she is and what she's
doing
definitely check that out obviously
that's something you're going to be part
of
yeah um let's talk about this then
before we finish like
yeah so you and i both know and people
listening you should know that
one of the biggest killers of young men
is mental health suicide
right this is important recruitment
industry is made up of a lot of
men and i think for me it's like and
this is why we're doing this right
which is why i'm so grateful for you to
be so open and talking about your
journey because i think
it starts with communication things can
really change in your life when
you talk and um but like how how do you
think we can get more men to be
vulnerable open up about their mental
challenges the things that you've
connie shared with us on this podcast
that's not easy for people
and they've never had to do that and
like how do you think
so we can start to move the needle
well you're right mate it's a massive
thing isn't it i think you know
i'm delighted to be an ambassador for uh
mental health and recruitment honestly i
think it's
the best thing uh since sliced bread i
think it's brilliant i think it's gonna
be transformative
and i'm glad you're part of it as well
max you've got a lot to offer um
i think in answers to your question it's
it's encouraging people like me
um to keep doing this and i i personally
will
continue to share i did a podcast for
that for under yesterday which is coming
out and it's it's
it's quite impactful actually i'll go
really deep into some of the stuff that
happened to me
and it's it's buddying up it's
communicating with people like me and
you
and other men who are doing something
and it's that and because that's what
happens when you've got mental health
yeah you you you feel there's a burden
to
to speak about it um so i've got
different whatsapp groups with just just
men on it just my mates and other
other people it's it's it's you know
instead of looking at facebook or
whatever look at look at
um mindfulness look at mindset look at
mental health
read up on it um and just just try and
and um identify people that are in the
same situation
and ask questions ask questions of your
friends as well and say look how you
know how are you doing or
even say you know when you're asked a
question how are you doing yeah all
right mate
why don't you answer actually mate i've
had a really bad day yesterday i just
want to let you know that
i was feeling pretty anxious yesterday
and it's
what you'll find is the other person you
probably think
has had that same [ __ ] as well that
sounds easy to say
um but i think that um
showing vulnerability is is an absolute
is courage it's not weakness
i'm not used to it but it's it's
honestly
to stand up or talk or even doing this
now you know is
it's i think it can bring so much
fulfillment in in
other people as well so i think i think
it's also you know be careful what
you're absorbing as well so i
you know i listen to lots of podcasts um
around um mental health and courage and
leadership so if you re if you really
are uh if you really do have mental
health uh or you are feeling anxious or
whatever that
is the only way to do it is is
i think look at what you're absorbing so
are you reading the facebook news are
you
why are you actually looking and reading
stuff that might help you
look at the people around you as well i
think i think i put a video on linkedin
last week around
you know the people around you have a
dramatic effect on how you feel
so some of the friends that you
associate with are they encouraging you
are they supporting you are they
reaching out to you
if if the answer is no honestly why are
you spending that you know do you always
make the first move
and really do i did an assessment almost
of my of
my friends and my people around me and
thought hold on a second
you know you're not you've never been
there for me well actually the guy that
always or the girl that always is
every time that person's been there for
me i haven't been there and it's like
actually so it's
it's what you're absorbing the people
that surround you being open
and um being compassionate to others as
well because i
i think every single person alive today
has some form of mental health
problem uh and that's the other thing i
don't want when they say mental health
issues i don't it's not an issue it's
it's reality
you know there's no the stigma is going
in fact
anyone who says they haven't got mental
health issues i think they actually have
problems with someone who has well i
think i think
the perfect comparison analogy is we all
have physical health if you look at
someone that might be overweight or
might tell you that they're ill all the
time or whatever and they've got ah
they've got some physical challenges or
like actual physical um issues
and it's the same as your mind like it's
just the exact
for me that's just a perfect analogy and
it's just it's just so much harder
because we can't see it
and that that's one of the challenges
but
no i love that i think that have making
the time to audit
what you're consuming couldn't agree
with that more that's so important i
think it's so easy
it's so easy just to get used to what
you consume and so
the people you look at and i have a real
audit of what
like you'll be surprised how many people
have an influence on your day that you
don't realize
why am i following that person on
instagram whenever i see their pictures
they make me feel inferior and they make
me feel not good enough and
whatever what okay it's about stopping
yourself in those moments and then why
am i following this person
why am i doing that and i think the
friends part also
i think that's one of the hardest things
right
is like this like if me knew a friend or
have been friends for the last
15 years and i've been on this journey
and through that i've got actually
i'm not sure how chris is a good like
how much of a good friend is how much
support you blah blah blah
there's so many things to back up why we
should stay friends
even though deep down i might know
you're not like for where i am
because that's one of the hardest things
right the friends part that that's
something that
i've been really grateful for is that
the sort of friends that i have we've
been on this journey together where
five years ago all i cared about was
what girls thought of me and all i cared
about was girls but and then
we've been through this journey together
of this self-discovery of working on
ourselves i'm actually thinking about
why are we on this planet what are we
doing having those conversations being
vulnerable and
if you unfortunately not everyone has
that
capability of being on that journey of
friends the person who was friends with
five years ago sort of still the same
person and cares about the same things
that you're not
that's it's difficult to break off from
stuff like that that's hard
it's not hard it is hard but then you've
only got one life and
um you know as you get as you get older
you know people reveal themselves to you
and you reveal them
yourself to them as well so don't get me
wrong this isn't a one-way street
you know there are i've lost friends
that you know they've kind of done that
to me because i haven't done it to them
so
the best way to look it is that
i if i treated my what the rest of my
life
how i treat my businesses in terms of
the focus the structure
and the and the importance of it i'd be
all right so
what i'm trying to say is i almost now
treat the rest of my life as a business
in terms of
kind of trying to maximize each of those
elements so the personal life the
friends the
personal development the exercise and
all that kind of stuff and if
i i can't check myself in so actually
mate when's the last time you exercised
when's the last
all that kind of stuff and what you'll
find is you'll have a better balance so
yeah sometimes you know i can be why
why can't i be so ruthless in business
and and very very weak and not be able
to set boundaries on personal life
and i think unless unless you those two
meetings so it's almost like
i need to be less ruthless and less hard
and more compassionate in business
and less compassion less empathy in my
purpose one of those where you should
see what i mean i think that's the way
to look at it gentlemen
definitely okay well look what um
what what are you excited about then
chris before we finish what sort of
obviously getting involved with uh
ronda you've got a few like i don't know
what how how do you view
i think it's amazing jen you've been on
last five months glad that you feel
good about the last 12 months how are
you feeling about the next
12 months mate i'm probably the most
excited i've ever been
actually um where i am now in terms of
where i feel i am in terms of my purpose
and my
ability to actually do something
tangible
i'm really excited about this mental
health initiative it's
probably the most exciting thing that's
happened to me i'm chuffed about my ned
stuff about giving back and coaching
leaders
and i think i think there's a lot of
transformative change around people's
mindsets so
i'm just excited to be alive and
helping people and pushing people
forward and
i think there was my oyster really and i
don't if you ask me what i want to do
you know uh i i'm an open book uh
i'm i'm willing to collaborate with
anyone um but i'm i'm
although there's a lot of adversity and
a lot of
um depression around or negativity
around where we are there's also a lot
of hope
a lot of a lot of positivity around um
different ways of thinking so i i'm very
excited about giving back
uh showing showing what i know and
helping others i love that chris
and look before before i sort of give
you an opportunity to
give sort of part in words like just
want to say yeah big thanks for being
super open and honest
on the show i really appreciate it and
that's not easy
as well what so yeah i guess part and
words for anyone that listened to this
that
might be going through some challenges
right now mentally or has sort of
listened to this and has resonated with
it and
i don't know what would sort of your
partner words be i guess if you was to
communicate to recruiters recruitment
business owners that are listening to
this that are sort of
identified with your story and your
journey
i think um that we're all human beings
everything no matter what level we're at
um we're all going through some [ __ ] and
we've all got some more [ __ ] to go
through and the only way to actually get
through that i think is to
let's try and put ourselves in a bit
more level playing field try and reach
out to as many people as possible
and show up as well so you know put
yourself like i'm like i'm doing this
isn't easy for me you know what i mean
you know i i could have done the
archetypal
you know look at my business
achievements all that kind of stuff and
i think just be a human being
you know don't be afraid to speak to
someone that you deem as superior
because they're not
but also don't be afraid to reach out to
someone who who's in who's in trouble
you know and it sounds a bit cheesy but
i just think
just try and put others first um if you
see them struggling but also if you're
struggling as well
you know like i said earlier take a step
back and say look do i have to take one
step back to go fight forward
do i have to park everything do i have
to remove some friends do i have to
dedicate an hour and a half no matter
what say to your wife no matter what i
want this hour and a half to do my
have that window of opportunity where
you can reflect and think and reassess
and then everything else should fall
into place amazing
chris thank you it's been a pleasure no
worries might really enjoy that good to
see